outside the Covenant School in Nashville
this was the evacuation of its pupils
children were escorted by police into
the arms of families who rushed to a
schoolgate reunion behind them they are
scene of mass murder
an incident lasting 14 minutes a 28 year
old woman killed three children and
three adults
while the shooting ensued pupils and
staff hid where they could my mom said
there was a shooter she said she was
hiding in the closet and that they were
shooting all over and that
they had potentially tried to get into a
room and just that she like loved us and
that they could just hear shooting like
all over the school
the killer was on with two assault
rifles a pistol was also found at the
scene she was shot dead by armed
officers on the second story of the
building
in the wake of the shooting this was the
scene at a property close to the school
officers looking into the perpetrators
background blew open the door and
conducted a search inside
from my initial findings is that at one
point she was a student at that school
but unsure what year all of that but
that's what I've been told so far
as a nation digested details of the
atrocity its president responded with a
repeated call for a ban on assault
weapons
it's heartbreaking a family's worst
nightmare
and I want to commend the police who
reply and responded incredibly swiftly
within minutes and the danger
we're monitoring the situation really
closely Ben as you know
and we have to do more to stop gun
violence it's ripping our communities
apart ripping a soul this nation ripping
into the very soul of the nation
if his words reflect a revolution Rich
large so the pictures from Nashville
with small children among the victims of
U.S gun violence the latest but almost
certainly not the last
James Matthews Sky News in Washington